[Music]
that's right major developments and the
Dunsey Smollett saga it continues a Cook
County Illinois judge is appointing a
special prosecutor to investigate the
handling of the case by a Chicago's top
prosecutor Kim Fox as you remember her
office dropped all charges against the
actor was a big surprise he was accused
of staging a hate crime attack on
himself it's tough to do the judge
saying that Fox did not have the right
to assign her top deputy to lead the
case after she colloquially recused
herself in his statement Fox said that
she disagrees with the judge's decision
so Emily this is really fascinating
because I you know you're a lawyer you
can explain this better but I was
wondering if there was some double
jeopardy in here but the special
prosecutor said that no they can reopen
the case and Jesse Smollett can be
charged once again with all 16 counts
fewer or even more yes and anyone else
that has been caught up in this can be
charged as well I want to point out for
viewers a couple things number one the
judge judge Tooman came out swinging at
Kim Fox he said essentially that her
that the phrase she used the acting
state's attorney who the acting county's
attorney basically was made up in her
imagination and therefore this is the
important part the arrest the subsequent
prosecution and the dropping of all
charges
therefore is inapplicable it's like
wiping the slate clean it's all moot and
that's why it restores the entire
situation back to the to that original
place secondly there's a whole host of
concurrent investigations happening and
here the defense was arguing well look
we're duplicating the efforts of the
inspector general judge two men
obviously said no you're not so right
now for viewers we have the inspector
general we have now a special prosecutor
we have the FBI investigating the hoax
we have the city of Chicago lawsuit
against Jesse for costs and then don't
forget the brothers who have sued his
attorneys a final point formation she
blamed her ethics yes she blamed her
ethics officer on it and remember she
ran on that platform of I'm going to
instill an ethics officer and bring
ethics back to the city of Chicago I'm
failed yeah other than the fact that
this is a high-profile actor and the
whole case is weird
really fascinated we are we are and you
know notwithstanding Emily what you say
Jessi small what's Jessie Jessie is not
they are not going to ignore or drop the
double jeopardy argument so this case is
gonna take a while if it ever comes to
trial and there will be substantial
arguments that it is double jeopardy and
my hunch is we might get a plea out of
this for a very modest effect I mean the
way he was talking about he he felt like
he was scot-free right you know he was
like I'm my mother's son and everyone
knows that I would never do anything
like this the real attackers are out
there American system is rigged because
Michelle Obama's former chief of staff
makes the call to Fox then he gets a
sweetheart deal Comey gives Hillary a
sweetheart deal
Hillary rigs the primary against Bernie
Muller stacks his team with 19 Democrats
celebrities are paying cash bribes to
get their kids into school sneaky Snipes
is messing around with the vote counts
it's all bogus if you're a regular
American who's working hard you feel
like if you're not someone who's
politically connected or rich you can't
really work the system in your favor so
that's why people are obsessed with the
story and they want to see Jesse pay a
price yeah because Lori Laughlin's not
going to go to them that I think Jesse
just came up with his book proposal you
have a you just did your table of
contents
okay I have to hand it to Smollett in
the sense that he didn't just sink his
own career he sunk the show Empire right
that's a and he's I think he's
destroying Kym Fox's career too
he's like that paint canister that bank
tellers slip into the money bag give to
the bank robbers and they're almost
there the whole thing just explodes and
they're covered in it my solution for
him and I've said this before is that he
should come clean and meet with the
people that he smeared he smeared these
imaginary Magga supporters if he
actually did a meet with actual Trump
supporters that could go towards a
certain path of forgiveness